وبهذا الشيء انتقل احساسي من من ممارسه
الطب واعطاء الادويه وكتابه المحاليل
والجرعات المناسبه لممارسه ليفل مختلف جدا
من الانسانيه كان الدرس الحقيقي في كورونا
انه لما كنا بنعمل المرور كان بيطلع
المرور طبيب واحد فقط عشان ما نعرض كل
الاطباء لانهم برضه يعني ممكن يتعدوا من
المرض فطبيب واحد كان بيمر على كل
العيانين المرور في العاده بيكون سؤال زي
حالك انت احسن اليوم الدواء الفلاني الدول
عنه فلان ومع السلامه
لكن المرور في كورونا كان شيء مختلف كنت
بحل قضايا مختلفه تماما بدخل على العيان
صباح الخير الاقي العيانه بتبكي ليه بتبكي
التكييف حار كلم الصيانه هاتوا التكنشن من
على البعد شغل التكييف هي ما بتبكي
التكييف حال لكن هي انسانيا تعبانه هي
قاعده في وضع في قمه ازمه كورونا وشايفه
اخبار العالم الناس بتموت عن اند وي ار في
الاخر كلنا ادخل الغرفه اللي بعدها القى
خالتو كبيره جدا في السن عيالها بيكلموها
بفيديو كول تعالي يا ماما كلمي اولادي في
الطبيعي انا ما برد على التلفونات وكل
الاطباء بالشكل ده لانه مش مسموحه انك
تتكلم مع حد مش موجود معاك في الغرفه لكن
الوضع كان اكسبشنل وتصرفاتنا ايضا كان
لابد انها تكون اكسبشنل فلقيت نفسي زي ما
بقولوا اخواننا المصريين بتشقلب اتكلم في
سكايب اسلم على ناس اعمل كبايه شاي يعني
عمري في حياتي ما تخيلت ان انا حاعمل
كبايه شاي واكون سعيده مش مش لانه انا
اعلى من كده ولا انه انا اسمى من كذا لانه
ببساطه
يعني لو سمحت اعمل لفلان لكن لما تلاقي
عمو كبير في السن 70 سنه لوحده في كوفيد
في عنبر محجور وشايفه الناس حوالينه بتكون
عايز تحسه
واحده من الحاجات اللي انا كنت بحكيها
لاصحابي ديورينج
انه ورايا
لقيت انه اي دودس انا بعمل الحاجات دي كل
يوم بغير قصدي مني وين لما تلاقي نفسك
بتشتكي لزميلتك او صاحبتك في الشغل انا
عندي صداع رهيب اسكتي انا عندي صداع اسوا
من الصداع اللي عندك لكن الاساس فيها
ازلاقه في ام بي سي لانه نحن ما بينخط
نفسنا محل البني ادم الثاني
حصل مره في حياتك فشلته في علاقه في
امتحان في شغل وحسيت انه انت شاكك في نفسك
انا لانه القاعه مضلمه
اللي حصل انه طول حياتي ماشيه بتراك معين
عندي اصدقاء هنا وعارفين يجهدولي يعني
وشغاله ومن البيت للشغل لشغل للبيت وصلنا
اخر امتحان خلاص خطوه وانتقل من نائب
اخصائي لاخصائي شايله اللابتوب تحت ايدي
ماشي المكتبه يا سلمى راجعه من المكتبه يا
سلمى ذاكري يا سلمى ساهر يا سلمى كبايه
الشاي يا سلمى خشي الامتحان يا سلمى
واسكتي
انا اسمي في الشاشه بتاعه الانترنت ما زلت
متذكره فتحت المجلس التخصصات سلمى عبد
الله المصباح لم يوفق انا لم يوفق بعد 18
سنه في ثانوي لم يوفق انا يتقال علي لم
يوفق
كانت مشكله كبيره جدا اند ايتولي
بدات انغلق على نفسي وهاتك يا عياط وهاتك
يا بكى وهاتك يا انهيار نفسي وانا اصلا ما
بعرف وانا اصلا سيئه وزملائي احسن مني
والناس اللي معايا في المستشفى اكيد
بيتكلموا علي وبيقولوا علي فاشله خلاص في
مرحله انا عايزه اسيب الجمل بما حمل واقفه
بتكلم مع سينيير عزيز جدا علي وصديقي جدا
دكتور ميشيل وبحكي في الكلام وببكي وفي نص
الكلام بقول له انا امتحن تاني ليه ما انا
فاشله
اول مره في كل السنين اللي انا بعرفه فيها
يعلي صوته علي ويقول لي مش مسموح تحكي عن
حالك هيك مش مسموح تحكي عن حالك فاشله
اندات
انتو ما يشوز كان ممكن يتعامل معايا كمدير
في والموظفه بتاعته وايه شغل العيال ده
وكل الناس بتمتحن وتسقطوا عادي يعني لكن
ده امتى تيجي
الاهتمام اللي اولاه لي ارجع البيت غسلي
وشك اطلعي مع اصحابك دي تجربه نحنا خذناها
ونقدر نخوضها تاني ما في امتحان بيحدد زول
ما في امتحان بيقول انت كلك منو الامتحان
جزء من البروسيس
من نائب اخصائي لاخصائي
يد ميشيل كانت زي ما قالت الست ام كلثوم
ويدين تمتد نحوي كيد من خلال الموجي مده
لغريق عظمه على عظمه يا ست
بتقول
بتتكلم فيه عن
ابحاث واحده من الاستديز دي اتعملت في 800
يعني هم ما قدروا
تقريبا كان في موظف غايب ليلتها او حاجه
بالشكل ده فتعبوني ان انا نحفظ الرقم
تاثير من الليدر شيب من يور دايركت
الكلام لكم
تاثير من
على الموظفين بتوعهم والنتيجه كانت مبهره
[موسيقى]
اكثر قدره على الابتكار
76%
في الشغل يعني بقوا مهتمين بالشغل اكثر
لانهم هم ذي فاوند من مدرائهم المبشرين
في الميه ديشود انهم
ذهاب ورك لايف بلانس ما عندهم مشكله ما
عندهم مشكله انهم يمشوا شغل وياخدوا مشاكل
الشغل البيت او ياخذوا مشاكل للبيت الشغل
لانه هم ايموشن اللي سبورتد في بيئه العمل
في المجال البزنس والبابليش عنده فيديو
جميل جدا بيتكلم فيه
بيئه العمل
شوهيجن انه انت
حساباتك في نص السنه الاولاني ضعيفه اعمل
حسابك
في حياتنا تخيل نفسيه الموظف ده وهو جاي
تاني يوم الشغل حيشتغل باي نفسيه ما انت
لسه امبارح مهددني نفس السي اي اودا
تخيلوا مع نفس الموظف وجاء قال نفس الكلام
على فكره
الاحصائيات بتاعتك في النص الاولاني من
السنه ضعيفه ارجوك
سؤال واحد بس هي شوت كير اي كير ما احنا
مش مكن احنا بني ادمين الموظفه اللي بيجي
لك ده امه بتمرض ابنه بيمرض زوجته بتتعب
ممكن يكون هو نفسيا تعبان عنده مشاكل مع
البنك البنزين غلي الدولار طلع
روسيا ضربت اوكرانيا مشاكل كثيره
بديهم الدافع انهم تفيل تفيل سيف يحسوا
بالامان في بيئه العمل
لما كنت بدرس
الطلبه عن التوكيسز اللي قارنته بيناتهم
حكيت لهم قصه حصلت
نحن كل يوم بنمشي المستشفى فاكرين انه نحن
بنعالج العيانين لكن الحقيقه انه العيانين
كمان بيعالجونا والعينين كمان هم بيدرسونا
انا شخصيا كل يوم
اتضربت من زوج او صديق بغض النظر وجاءت
وانا كتبت لها الشكوى بتاعه الشرطه يوجد
كذا كذا كذا وديت الورقه فبقول لها راجعي
يا مدام الكلام اللي مكتوب ده مزبوط يوجد
خدش يوجد جرح يوجد كدمه
وهي بتعين لي وشها كله بكى ونفسها مكسوره
قالت لي يا دكتوره وكسرت النفس مين بده
يحكي عنا
كسرت نفس البني ادم ما بتتسجل في تقارير
الشرطه ما بتتكتب في الفايلات
ملهاش ميزان تخدته تاخد كسره نفس البني
ادم وتقول نفسه مكسوره بالقدر الفلاني
بيكون تعرض لضرب احيانا بيكونوا حتى رجال
تخانقوا مع بعض في الشغل في مكتب في
الشارع كسرت علي بعربيتك بيجي نفسيته
تعبانه
المريض الوحيد احنا في الطوارئ دايما
وانتو شفتوا طوارئ قبل كده بنكون بنتكلم
مع العيان ونحن واقفين وعايزين نمشي
للعيانه اللي بعده المريض الوحيد اللي انا
بسحب الكرسي واقعد جنبه هو المريض اللي
تعرض للصوت والمريض اللي بحسه في عينيه في
وشه فعلا احساس كسره النفس it my studits
ذا اونلي
والشيء الوحيد اللي ما بيميز بين الناس
الالم نفسي او عضوي لا بيعرفك انت اسود لا
بيعرفك انت ابيض لا بيعرف عرق لا بيعرف
دين لا بيعرف بلد لو اي واحد فينا طلع هنا
من القاعه ولا سمح الله ضربته عربيه نفس
الالم هيحصل لاي واحد فينا وبالتالي نحن
كلنا بغض النظر عن اختلافاتنا شركاء في
الالم ولابد لابد لابد اننا نكون شركاء في
التعاطف زي ما نحن شركاء في الالم
العالم حولنا مليء بالكراهيه بالاحقاد في
الحروب بالنازحين نحن استنينا لحد ما
الكورونا تجي عشان نتعاطف مع الناس واحنا
كان المفروض نشوف البني ادم بيموت عشان
نتعاطف معه عشان نمد يدنا نحن كان لازم
ننتظر لما زلزال يطبق الارض على الناس
عشان نتعاطف معاهم ونقول حرام هم قاعدين
في العراء لهم سنين مش مفروض ننتظر انه
الامور تصل الى هذا الحد عشان نحس بالشيء
الوحيد اللي بيثبت امكانيتنا وهو تعاطف
بعضنا مع الاخر نحن لما نتخانق مع بعض في
نقاش عادي جدا بتلاقي صوتك علي وبتقول
للبني ادم القدامي يا اخي خلي نفسك مكاني
كنت حتعمل ايه خلي نفسك مكان البني ادم
الثاني
كنت حتحس بايه
مريض كبير جدا جدا
عمره حوالي يمكن 78 سنه وجات معاه زوجه
المستشفى وهي برضو ست كبيره في السنه مش
اقل من 65 سنه دخلوا الانعاش وانا دخلت
معاهم هو تعبان وضعيف جدا ومتالم وحمى
عاليه وضغط نازل وسكر عالي وهي واقفه جنبي
وبتحكي عنده يا دكتوره وعنده وعنده وعنده
وبياخد الدواء ده وبيشرب الحبوب دي وبقى
له يومين ما اكلش بنفس الكلام ده يقوم هو
يئن
[موسيقى]
تنط من جنبي الست الكبيره دي تنط من جنبي
وتيجي تقف جنب راسه وتحط راسه جنب راسها
وتقول له ما تخافش يا حبيبي انا جنبك اهو
انا جنبك يا محمد ما تخافش
افري
انا جنبك يا حبيبي ما تخافش قبل ما تنكر
او السوبرا
شكرا
شكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا شكرا